good morning well first of all thank you
mauricio and melinda for
um and brian getting everybody here um
and all all the members of the media
thank you for joining
uh this morning just wanted to be here
to provide an
update on where we are um the decision
um as i mentioned last night i've been
my prepared remarks
you know this is not in um you know in a
way
delaying the planning the planning will
continue
um you know it was uh following the
governor's
order of state home nevada 2.0 which was
um
the right thing to do is looking at the
numbers
um you know i felt that it was something
that wanted to discuss one more time
with the board publicly
up as we continue to plan to move
hopefully bring our children back when
the health data
and the numbers allow us to do that in
in the first of the year sometime in
january we don't have a specific date or
a target
our goal is to work as a second largest
employer in the state
keeping everybody safe numbers go down
and it'll be a way for us to bring
our children and our employees into the
buildings in schools
as i've stated many times before we are
not only in the midst of a health crisis
but we are also
being challenged with a mental health
crisis and an academic crisis for our
children
so safety has and will continue to be
the top priority for me and the board
but i wanted to give an opportunity for
us to review
our transition plan to hybrid um
whenever that time comes in january
and now i'll turn it over to mauricio to
answer any questions
thank you so much dr jar i'll be going
down the list folks we'll start with uh
jeff gilland with channel three
jeff uh folks uh
dr jar good good to see you and thank
you for taking my questions
what metrics dr jarrah are you going to
use
in order to um determine when
what kind of timetable you're looking at
what specifically will you need to see
to start rolling this plan into effect
yeah no and you know what one of the
things that we continue to look at and
as i said
i mentioned last night i sit with uh in
the regional policy group every monday
afternoon with the southern nevada
health district umc
the county officials all our
municipalities as we were looking at at
the health data and the health numbers
the positivity rate increase
uh to me it just gave me pause and and
one of the things that we want to look
at is to start seeing a downward trend
but then the other thing is is to start
looking at what we are doing and making
sure that our
our employees will be safe and and
helping us with the plan is
a very solid plan uh it's got all the
safety measures
i've been finalizing um proud of the
board's decision last night
to bring in and tie in the health day
the health
the ties program which gives us an
opportunity to now
um a voluntary rate for to to test our
employees
i think that was one of the measures
that our ccea
has been working with us um to put
together
it brings some some level of comfort so
now we have that in place so now that's
something that's been added
um to to our plan um so
so those are some of the measures that
we're looking to see
um you know i like to see the numbers
lower um but i think
you know um that's that's one of the
things that we continue to look at the
monitor
i have one follow-up if i can just very
quickly dr gerard
how many students um have you lost
this semester when i say lost what i
mean that you that have fallen out of
touch that you're not in contact with i
know that that had been a problem last
year
at the end of end of school are you
still having that problem now
you know i'm gonna say i i don't have
the exact number
um but we haven't seen what we are
seeing and this is anecdotal
uh what we're looking at seeing is um
the engagement
um you know the kids uh especially the
older kids they're making some decisions
uh our teachers are working hard trying
to engage i had a i had a listening tour
with educators
uh support professionals and and our
administrators in the last couple weeks
and what i'm hearing
anecdotally is that it's it's tough to
engage and
engage continue to engage our students
online they're making some different
choices
um so that's been a bit of a challenge
okay
that's all that and i'll pass it on to
my colleagues
thank you jeff uh i believe we have
lauren with channel five
lauren hi
hi there dr jara my name is lauren
martinez um i'm new to the team
so this is my first week um i wanted to
ask you
um well my main question is now that
trustees and the board has more time
to look over this what kind of changes
would you like to see in the next
proposal
so so uh well first of all welcome to
the team and welcome
welcome to thank you to um
the education beat i guess i would say
um you know one of the things that we're
looking at is really and i heard loud
and clear one of the things is
it's really a bit more consistent in in
our in our instructional
um support of our of our teachers and
our families so
we're going to look at you know making
sure that uh when we're providing the
curriculum and the lessons
that it's available for for our teachers
um there so i think it's a little bit
more of a standardization
of where and how we're delivering the
curriculum our families
from what i'm hearing are frustrated so
that's one of the things that we're
we're going to really uh bring back into
the plan
for when we come back to school
so would you say that there's um more of
a focus
on distance learning right now um
in instead of this transitional plan or
would you say that's kind of split right
well kind of 50 50.
i think it's both uh the focus that
we're going to have we have we have to
improve the distance education program
um because when we come back we're still
going to have families that are going to
up there because they're going to be a
choice
for families to keep to keep their
children home
so we still have to improve the improve
what we're doing there
as well so it's going to be a little of
both of what we have to do
okay thank you thank you lauren we have
kate houston with channel 8 kate
yes good morning um dr jarrah you
mentioned we are
in a mental health crisis and in light
of the news that
another student died of suicide how is
the district going to be supporting
families right now especially now that
these plans have been postponed
you know um kate one of the things that
we started as a pilot this past week is
uh
is a program we're bringing in our and
and and i'll say this we it's more of an
not that we just started this program
that our social workers our counselors
have been working tirelessly across the
district this goes back to
you know it's what we're seeing i think
what we're seeing is the social
the social isolation and some of these
different things and aspects of what
we're doing so
we're bringing in we we've identified
some schools that are piloting
uh more of an intense support with
social workers counselors
administrators what we're calling with
the mlt team that's coming in and really
spending time with our three
three tier three students that are
struggling um socially so we can reach
out
and doing that we're going to continue
with our with our wellness checks we're
going to continue doing that across the
district
we're just providing some intensive
support in the 11 schools that we've
identified where we're seeing
where we're seeing some of these
concerns but they're going to be
coming in um they're they were doing it
voluntarily coming into the schools um
obviously following the governor's
orders and
i'm staying home but these are critical
these are essential these are lives
of our children um we've lost we've lost
more
you know more this year than all of last
year in in
in this first semester so this is the
sense of urgency that we need to have
around around our kids lives
thank you so much we have uh is there
someone from channel 13 who has a
question
all right i believe they're just
recording um we have uh
julie with a review journal julie
good morning superintendent jara um i
was wondering if you could please
clarify whether you anticipate bringing
the hybrid plan back to the board in
december and then
what the process would be and what steps
you would be looking to take to
make any revisions to the plan based on
the feedback that the board provided
last
night yeah so so julie one of the things
that when we look at the hybrid
um there's there's a lot of different
components um this is you know we've
already analyzed and looked at you know
half day million kids in the half day
you know and then bringing a
different cohort in the in the afternoon
you know those those things that
as much as we'd like to do up in
different ways
we have to follow the cdc guidelines the
cdc guidelines keeps our kids we have to
keep our kids in different cohorts
um so it's not you know that that you
know the the criticism is well this is
the only plan no there's
the guidelines that are put in place are
for you know for us to be able to do the
contact tracing
and the implementation and just getting
our kids in school somehow so
it's going to be you know looking at
what the board has given us as advice or
recommendations to look at a little bit
further we'll analyze that
um you know i i see that um there may be
some potential changes but really not
too far
because we you know the the social
distancing is going to be a six feet
uh it has to be a six feet for us um and
and uh and the mask and different things
because the safety
of the students and and the teachers are
and the adults
is the top priority so we can bring more
than
the 50 capacity as well so it is going
to be some type of hybrid
thank you so much we have uh sarah with
the las vegas sun
sarah
all right we'll come back to you uh
jackie valley with the nevada
independent
hi dr dara um i want to piggyback off
julie's question a little bit
uh we have it looks like we have two
board meetings the rest of this year
um i anticipate we won't have this come
up
next week but can you clarify whether it
could potentially be on
the board agenda for the december 10th
meeting
uh yeah i i guess i missed that now to
answer that question i mean that's my
goal my goal is to bring something back
in december
okay and then uh as a follow-up
last night you mentioned that you were
very close to some form of agreement
with
different unions can you clarify what
unions and
exactly like what type of agreements um
or sticking points
you're working on with them yeah i know
jackie while i can't give you the
details of what the agreement that we're
working on because i don't want to
bargain in the public but it's with ccea
cca
is um has been a partner with us uh and
trying to find ways to open up our
schools
okay and then lastly we heard a somewhat
consistent message from several trustees
saying that we really should be focusing
on
improving distance learning and remote
learning given
so many uncertainties with case numbers
how do you plan to address
that and will we see any of that
information folded in possibly december
10th
yeah i think it's uh jackie it goes back
to the question um
that i just that i um that i was asked
about really the standardization of the
curriculum and where the lessons are i
think there's a lot of different
frustrations from parents from what
we're hearing
is that in some schools they have to go
through google me
but now let's go through canvas and i
think that is the piece where we have to
start
improving and what the lessons are
putting in place and then the grading
and the expectations to have a more
standard support and i think
you know that's that's one of the goals
for us to get that in place for
um for us whether it's you know whether
we go in the hybrid or where we stay in
distance education so standardizing some
of the expectations across the entire
school district
is one of the things that that i heard
loud and clear
thank you thank you sarah i know you're
communicating with brian so once we
have your questions from the las vegas
sun we will be sure to ask them on your
behalf
is there a representative from the
nevada current
nevada current
all right i'll turn it to spanish for a
couple minutes uh
do you have a question
[Music]
[Music]
all right if you're having technical
difficulties feel free to type your
comments here or
send a quick name out of the
communications email account uh
ryan if you finally checked that for us
i'll go back
one last question i'll go back in
reverse
nevada currents is there anyone on there
brian any questions from sonia
you want to unmute yourself still
waiting right now
so i think we'll get something she's
been she emailed that she was having
problems getting unmuted so i will get
that appreciate that
uh jackie valley did you have one last
question
can you come back to me in a second yeah
of course uh julie with the review
journal
julie julie review journal
all right channel 13
channel 8 kate houston
yes hi just kind of touching back on the
question
in regards to that pilot program that
you mentioned will that be
expanded to all schools and with that um
if the hybrid plan goes through will
that still go on
while kids are back in the classroom
yeah okay
that's our goal is to increase increase
the access
and provide more support across across
all the schools we wanted to start small
and
and making sure that we work out um some
of the challenges
um especially during distance education
but you know that
while we are in the hybrid if that's
where we when we end up in opening our
schools
then that is something that um you know
the mental health
of our kids and our employees is going
to be it's a priority for us so
absolutely
thank you so much i do have one question
from sarah with the las vegas sun she
was just hoping to get a little more
information about the
uh testing program for our um
employees if you can just discuss that a
little bit how that might work
yeah well basically it's voluntary as
the board approved it last night it was
about it's voluntary
um for our um
for our employees to participate through
through for covert testing and then
there's they'll follow an app
up and you know it's it's a statewide
program um
we just approved it last night the
follow-on app and then obviously
is is you know for the contact tracing
um
you know if if it's um you know there's
positivity and then be able to provide
that
that safety measure for our employees
appreciate it thank you so much i'm
going to jump back to
uh channel 5. lauren did you have
another question
lauren channel five
all right i'll move on to uh hello yeah
are you there
go ahead oh yeah sorry okay great um so
the reporter that covered this last
night
she did have a question um she said the
reason
why there seems to be such a push to get
back into the classroom before the end
of the year
was to retain the cares act money
do you know what happens with that now
no i don't there first of all let me
just say we were coming back
um before the beginning of the before
the end of the year and the carrick
dollars does run out on december 31st
according to the federal government
um our planet that you saw in the hybrid
last night
before the board was for the beginning
uh in january to start coming back to
school
okay thank you thank you
thank you lauren uh jeff gilliam channel
3.
uh dr jarrah i i wanted to get back to
the mental health piece here
what what is the number of suicide
student suicides that you've seen so far
at ccsd this year
um as of the number as of today 11
11. and you said that you were targeting
that there
are i just want to make sure i
understood you correctly
there are 11 schools that you've seen
particular issues with this at is that
correct
well what i say is the 11 schools is
where we're seeing that there's a
greater need of support
for students it may not be where the
whether we're the situation where we've
lost our lives
the lives it's just it's really from the
contact in our schools and our
principals and our teachers
uh monitoring the their data do you
think that those suicides sir
are are related to the fact that we're
in distance learning and that we are
the or or or could other factors be at
play here do you think
yeah jeff i think i think that's a
that's a great question and one of the
things that i
look i mean you know there's days that i
there's days that i struggle
uh you know it just really it's uh with
with with cobit19
um when you really look at it and i
think i think i i can't tell you i'm not
an expert to tell you that that it is
uh but when you really look at um the
social isolation when you when you look
at you know
what's happening in the economy at home
uh you know there's a lot of factors and
kids not being in school um so that's
that's that's the biggest concern that
we all have and
and our adults are facing it as well so
um you know
we're we're trying to bring some
normalcy back into our kids lives
uh and our educators as well so you know
i can't say that it is the only
factor but it's trying to bring life
back to our to our our students and our
families
thank you thank you jeff i'll go back to
you jackie valley do you have a question
yes i wanted to ask about the third part
of the crisis and that's the academic
portion
um we've soon note that attendance has
dropped student engagement has been a
struggle
what are um different teachers or
principals doing
to try to boost that especially like we
have the holidays approaching
and a bummer with the the coven
news as well yeah you know jackie uh one
of the things that and again with
that i heard from our teachers and our
listening tours they're just trying
every every way to being find engagement
they're playing games
you know they're spending some time at
the beginning of the lesson
uh to get them to turn their cameras on
uh
voluntarily so then they can play games
and engage the kids into
what they're doing is just so much
harder right doing it
virtually than doing it in the classroom
so so where kids are
fine you know they're finding ways to
feel comfortable at home
um through this distance education
modality
um so that's what i'm hearing they're
you know just kind of
just trying to personalize it bring some
some
you know not a show and tell but you
know kind of some of those games
to engage kids in the classrooms
okay thank you all right thank you so
much folks i do have two questions from
kalamundo feel free to
uh stay on if you'd like folks but uh
this concludes the
english section of today's media
availability i really do appreciate it
you can log off now i will be asking uh
two questions on behalf of
mundo um dr jar they were just hoping to
see if you can talk to them in spanish
real quick
a message for parents of what happens
next with um
with our transitional plan
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
thank you so much for uh to everyone
else for participating
thank you have a good weekend